Oh grandparents generation create an
amazing system of canals and reservoirs
it made it possible for people to live
in places where there wasn't a lot of
water for example during the Great
Depression they created the Hoover Dam
which in turn created Lake Mead and made
it possible for the cities of Las Vegas
and Phoenix and Los Angeles to provide
water for people who lived in a really
dry place in the 20th century we
literally spent trillions of dollars
building infrastructure to get water to
our cities in terms of economic
development it was a great investment
but in the last decade we've seen the
combined effects of climate change
population growth and competition for
water resources threaten these vital
lifelines and water resources
this figure shows you the change in the
lake level of Lake Mead that happened in
the last 15 years you can see starting
around the year 2000 the lake level
started to drop and it was dropping at
such a rate that it would have left the
drinking water intakes for Las Vegas
high and dry the city became so
concerned about this that they recently
constructed a new drinking water intake
structure that they refer to as the
third straw to pull water out of the
greater depths of the lake the
challenges associated with providing
water to a modern city are not
restricted to the American Southwest in
the year 2007 the third largest city in
Australia Brisbane came within six
months of running out of water
a similar dramas playing out today in
South Paulo Brazil where the main
reservoir for the city has gone from
being completely folded in 2010 to being
nearly empty today as the city
approaches the 2016 Summer Olympics for
those of us who are fortunate enough to
live in one of the world's great cities
we've never truly experienced the
effects of a catastrophic drought we
like to complain about the navy showers
we have the
we like our neighbors to see our dirty
cars and our brown Long's but we've
never really faced the prospect that of
turning on the tap and having nothing
come out and that's because when things
have gotten bad in the past it's always
been possible to expand a reservoir or
dig a few more groundwater wells well in
a time when all of the water resources
are spoken for it's not going to be
possible to rely on this tried-and-true
way of applying ourselves of water now
some people think that we're gonna solve
the urban water problem by taking water
from our rural neighbors but that's an
approach that's fraught with political
legal and social dangers and even if we
succeed in grabbing the water from our
rural neighbors we're just transferring
the problem to someone else and there's
a good chance it'll come back and bite
us in the form of higher food prices and
damage to the aquatic ecosystems that
already rely upon that water now I think
that there's a better way to solve our
urban water crisis and I think that's to
open up for new local sources of water
that I like into faucets if we can make
smart investments in these new sources
of water in the coming years we can
solve our urban water problem and
decrease the likelihood that we'll ever
run across the effects of a catastrophic
drought now if you told me 20 years ago
that a modern city could exist without a
supply of imported water I probably
would have dismissed you as an
unrealistic and uninformed dreamer but
my own experience is working with some
of the world's most water starved cities
in the last decades have shown me that
we have the technologies and the
management skills to actually transition
away from imported water and that's what
I want to tell you about tonight the
first source of local water supply that
we need to develop to solve our urban
water problem will flow at the rainwater
that falls in our cities one of the
great tragedies of at urban development
is that as our cities grew we started
covering all the surfaces with concrete
and asphalt and when we did that we had
to build storm sewers to get the water
that fell on the cities out before it
could cause
and that's a waste of a vital water
resource let me give you an example this
figure here shows you the volume of
water that could be collected in the
city of San Jose if they could harvest
the stormwater that fell within the city
limits you can see from the intersection
of the blue line and the black dotted
line that if San Jose could just capture
half of the water that fell within the
city they'd have enough water to get
them through an entire year now I know
what some of you are probably thinking
the answer to our problem is to start
building great big tanks and attaching
them to the downspouts of our roof
gutters rainwater harvesting now that's
an idea that might work in some places
but if you live in a place where it
mainly rains in the wintertime and most
of the water demand is in the summertime
it's not a very cost-effective way to
solve a water problem and if you
experience the effects of a multi-year
drought like California is currently
experiencing
you just can't build a rainwater tank
that's big enough to solve your problem
I think there's a lot more practical way
to harvest the storm water and the
rainwater that falls in our cities and
that's to capture it and let it
percolate into the ground after all many
of our cities are sitting on top of a
natural water storage system that could
accommodate huge volumes of water for
example historically Los Angeles has
obtained about a third of its water
supply from a massive aquifer that
underlies the San Fernando Valley now
when you look at the water that comes
off of your roof and runs off of your
lawn and flows down the gutter you might
say to yourself do I really want to
drink that stuff well the answer is you
don't want to drink it until it's been
treated a little bit and so the
challenge that we face in urban water
harvesting is to capture the water clean
the water and get it underground and
that's exactly what the city of Los
Angeles is doing with a new project that
they're building in Burbank California
this figure here shows the storm water
park that they're building by hooking a
series of stormwater collection system
or storm sewers and routing that water
into an abandoned gravel quarry the
water that's captured in the quarry then
is slowly passed or a man-made
wetland and then it goes into that ball
field there and percolates into the
ground recharging the drinking water
aquifer of the city and in the process
of passing through the wetland and
percolating through the ground the water
encounters microbes that live on the
surfaces of the plants and the surfaces
of the soil and that purifies the water
and if the waters still not clean enough
to drink after it's been through this
natural treatment process the city can
treat it again when they pump it back
out of the groundwater aquifers before
they deliver it to people to drink the
second tap that we need to open up to
solve our urban water problem will flow
with the wastewater that comes out of
our sewage treatment plants now many of
you are probably familiar with the
concept of recycled water you've
probably seen signs like this that tell
you the shrubbery and the highway median
and the local golf course is being
watered with water that used to be in a
sewage treatment plant we've been doing
this for a couple of decades now but
what we're learning from our experiences
is that this approach is much more
expensive than we expected it to be
because once we build the first few
water recycling systems close to the
sewage treatment plant we have to build
longer and longer pipe networks to get
that water to where it needs to go and
that becomes prohibitive in terms of
cost what we're finding is that a much
more cost-effective impractical way of
recycling waste water is to turn treated
wastewater into drinking water through a
two-step process in the first step in
this process we pressurize the water and
pass it through a reverse osmosis
membrane a thin permeable plastic
membrane that allows water molecules to
pass through but traps and retains the
salts the viruses and the organic
chemicals that might be present in the
wastewater in the second step in the
process we add a small amount of
hydrogen peroxide and shine ultraviolet
light on the water the ultraviolet light
Cleaves the hydrogen peroxide into two
parts that are called hydroxyl radicals
and these hydroxyl radicals are very
potent forms of oxygen that break down
most organic chemicals after the waters
been through this two-stage process it's
safe to drink
I know I've been studying recycled water
using every measurement technique known
to modern science for the past 15 years
we've detected some chemicals that can
make it through the first step in the
process but by the time we get to that
second step the advanced oxidation
process we rarely see any chemicals
present and that's in stark contrast to
the taken-for-granted water supplies
that we regularly drink all the time
there's another way we can recycle water
this is an engineered treatment wetland
that we recently built on the Santa Ana
River in Southern California the
treatment wetland receives water from a
part of the Santa Ana River that in the
summertime consists almost entirely a
wastewater effluent from cities like
Riverside and San Bernardino the water
comes into our treatment wetland it's
exposed to sunlight and algae and those
break down the organic chemicals remove
the nutrients and inactivate the
waterborne pathogens the water gets put
back in the Santa Ana River it flows
down to Anaheim gets taken out at
Anaheim and percolate it into the ground
and becomes the drinking water of the
city of Anaheim completing the trip from
the sewers of Riverside County to the
drinking water supply of Orange County
now you might think that this idea of
drinking wastewater is some sort of
futuristic fantasy or not commonly done
well in California we already recycle
about 40 billion gallons a year of
wastewater through the two-stage
advanced treatment process I was telling
you about that's enough water to be the
supply of about a million people if it
were their soul water supply the third
tap that we need to open up will not be
a tap at all it'll be kind of a virtual
tap it'll be the water conservation that
we managed to do and the place where we
need to think about water conservation
is outdoors because in California and
other modern American cities about half
of our water use happens outdoors in the
current drought we've seen that it's
possible to have our lawns survive and
our plants survive with about half as
much water so there's no need to start
painting concrete green and putting an
astroturf and buying cactuses we can
have California friendly lands
with soil moisture detectors and smart
irrigation controllers and have
beautiful green landscapes in our cities
the fourth and final water tap that we
need to open up to solve our urban water
problem will flow with desalinated
seawater now I know what you've probably
heard people say about seawater
desalination it's a great thing to do if
you have lots of oil not a lot of water
and you don't care about climate change
sea water desalination is energy
intensive no matter how you slice it
but that characterization of seawater
desalination as being a non-starter is
hopelessly out of date we've made
tremendous progress in sea water
desalination in the past two decades
this picture shows you the largest
seawater desalination plant in the
Western Hemisphere that's currently
being built north of San Diego compared
to the seawater desalination plant that
was built in Santa Barbara
25 years ago this treatment plant will
use about half the energy to produce a
gallon of water but just because
seawater desalination has become less
energy intensive doesn't mean we should
start building desal plants everywhere
among the different choices we have it's
probably the most energy intensive and
potentially environmentally damaging of
the options to create a local water
supply so there it is with these four
sources of water we can move away from
our reliance on imported water through
reform in the way we landscape our
surfaces and our properties we can
reduce outdoor water use by about 50
percent thereby increasing the water
supply by 25 percent
we can recycle the water that makes it
into the sewer thereby increasing our
water supply by 40 percent and we can
make up the difference through a
combination of storm water harvesting
and sea water desalination so let's
create a water supply that will be able
to withstand anything any of the
challenges that climate change throws at
us in the coming years let's create a
water supply that uses local sources and
leaves more water in the environment for
fish and for food let's create a water
system that's consistent with our
environmental values and let's do it for
our children and our grandchildren
and let's tell them this is the system
that they have to take care of in the
future because it's our last chance to
create a new kind of water system thank
you very much for your attention